on joue pour un kilo de bombes comment
s'appelait paris à l'époque des gaulois
comment s'appelait paris à l'époque des
gaulois c'est juste mais dit sartre
attention vous allez me paie 10 à 8 n 7
bat j'imagine mais où vous habitez
week-end lui teindre island moi je mange
108 m2 au loyer une émotion alors
mélissa c'est bon c'est gagné bravo
bénéficient mais remise à plat pour une
angoisse soit question sinistre en vaut
deux parce que nous si on répond mal on
sait qu'on est des remarques m et
mélissa theuriau alors elle m'a répondu
à la question de ses mains on était très
mal le mali n'ont pas et tous les tweets
la preuve vivante qu'on peut être belle
talentueuse intelligente c'est une
journaliste sympathique très
professionnelle faire des reportages
pour ouvrir les débats excellente
journaliste un blessé docs sont parfaits
bref j'adore je vous le dis bien marquer
là que du positif
[Applaudissements]
et je vais vous faire un aveu et je le
dis tout téléspectateur quand ses moyens
je fais allez on n'a pas eu de tweets
c'est que voilà et je suis la personne
qui tu aimes le plus sur ce plateau km
[Rires]
alain défaut quand même c'est quoi il
marie elle heureuse en amour
bah ouais mais ça nous fait plaisir ça
fait à la mi temps que ce avec un ami
chabat et c'est avec un ennemi on
l'aurait foutu dehors on leur jeter des
pierres
comme annoncé vrai dire regardez
regardez où es tu veux faire quoi en
politique mais j'aimerais bien un jour
moins dix journalistes d'accord comme
quand même comme mélissa toi politique
eh ben voilà journaliste politique moi
c'est me mélissa css et un petit modèle
wi et génial oui